what do you do to get yourself in the
right space before you go out there and
do a show well I'm getting older so it's
a lot of uh
I I think it would be the same thing
that you would imagine a retired
footballer would do if you said you have
to play this afternoon a lot of creaking
and stretching and yeah
asking people to manipulate this and
loosen that and you know it's that kind
of thing I've gotten into trouble asking
people that yeah please could you
manipulate this and please manipulate me
why am I being sued uh as the venues
become the same
as Sports so the preparations do too
that makes sense to me
um when I think when we were playing in
bars I don't drink but the rest of the
band were drinking
when we were playing in arenas the rest
of them were doing you know Arena type
stuff and when you're playing stadiums
it's like preparing for a big soccer
game or a big NFL game and you know
you're gonna
get some muscle issues and yeah oh I
also think even though I I've I have had
people make fun of me because I'll be
about to do a show where I'm sitting and
chatting with someone and I'm stretching
and people say what are you stretching
for you're not gonna in any way do
anything slightly athletic and I say
it's something about preparing I need to
do something for myself that gets me to
a slightly elevated yeah I think that
comes from physical stuff and from
uniforms I think that
we see it all around the world anyone
that's given a uniform to to
um enforce a rule yeah can do it very
very firmly when they have their uniform
but if they were wearing shorts and a
t-shirt you wouldn't take them seriously
right in the same way that I could not
go on stage dressed like this I would
not be able to do it I have to put on my
uniform which looks pretty similar looks
pretty similar but I know it's my band
uniform yeah that makes sense to me
though too because I've always felt
it isn't it's a perform a performance
has to be slightly you get to a slightly
different place than we're sitting here
I'm wearing jeans you're wearing sweats
we're chatting if there was an audience
here
I sometimes even if I'm I'll put on a
tie even if it's not required I just
feel that I need to do something that
shows that I'm an ice cream man and I
put on my ice cream man uniform yeah
well this is a cool I don't know if this
is interesting but it's been on my mind
because I I got told that I got in
trouble for not dressing up enough for
the Grammys
although my partner said you did dress
up you put shoes on
I wish which was a true and being really
kind yeah
but I was thinking about
I am happy to
feel like I have to wear an outfit if it
helps me perform better but I don't
agree with telling people what they have
to wear yeah maybe that's a hangover
from school where you're told you have
to wear this or
I I
um
I was I was I need to write A Treatise
on this like
the sort of clothing uh
rules yeah well it seems like it it it's
it's
because well first of all it's the
Grammys and it's representing all
different kinds of music and free
expression so the idea that you need to
dress up for the Grammys
does clothing show respect and and I
would never want to show disrespect so
because I love the Grammys so
so I was interested maybe I was wrong or
maybe
maybe we're sort of brainwashed to
thinking if you're not wearing a tuxedo
you can't get married kind of thing
right right of course you can if you're
hot you know what what if you're an Ax
Murderer and you're dressed correctly
are you a better groom than Woody
Harrelson over here who loves you with
all his heart but is wearing board
shorts right right right no you're not
but they didn't know the answer
and I think Woody is very violent uh in
my experience I I I'm going to give a
big shout out to Woody Harrelson because
he was at a concert of Oswald he was so
kind to my brother when he had no reason
to be that he just became an extra hero
in my eyes well that's nice when
obviously people are nice to you
but
it's it's so delightful when you find
out who someone really is when they're
being when you find out later on that
they talked for 20 minutes the person
who is installing cable you know it I
don't know I love that when when people
reveal their true kindness through just
uh well he did another thing too it
wasn't performative yeah something I
learned from my dad is that you
everybody is interesting if you ask them
questions everybody
and my dad is amazing at that and he
comes out on tour a lot
and he doesn't necessarily know who
people are from movies so he talks to
our crew a lot and a lot of them have
names like bash or hoppy Mystic things
like that and then he met this guy
called Woody
and he started talking about you know
what do you do do you fold the cables
and it was Woody Harrelson
and
hello Woody
like this
and then he told you I met this lovely
fellow named Woody yeah and uh and again
Woody Harrelson was cool as and
well I was uh many years ago had a party
and Jim Carrey was there and my mother
was there and at one point my mother I
see my mother talking to Jim Carrey and
I'm thinking oh God what's happening and
then she came over to me and she went I
just talked to the loveliest young man
his name's Jim
and I said oh oh you talked to Jim and
she was like yes and I told him if you
want to be in comedy you stick with it
and they're gonna try and put you down
but you keep of course he had had like
nine he was the biggest star in the
world at the time and I said Mom all I
want you to do is go back to Boston and
tell your friends you told Jim Carrey to
stick with comedy that's great and uh
she did and got laughed out of town
that's amazing I had I was visiting my
friend who had cancer at the time in New
York in hospital and I was coming down
in the elevator with a nurse in all her
glory like six pens in the pocket like
you know
and um I was singing it not loudly not
like hey check this out yeah but I was
mumbling or something and she said oh
you have a beautiful voice
and I said oh thank you so much
she said you know you should uh you
should do something with that and I and
I said and I said oh yeah well maybe and
she said also you look like the guy from
Coldplay
this is really true and I said okay yeah
people say that and she said you know
what you should do you should call
restaurants and say that you're him
because you would get really good tables
and then she left
foreign